[Music]
same land game
and uh
let's start
uh
with a couple of warm-up puzzles so uh
for the audience here live
there is gonna also be an online
audience today unlike on thursday which
is why
yeah the the content will be
a bit more advanced than it was on
thursday just because there's
sometimes masters show up in the in the
youtube and some very very strong
players
um but i'll try to do my best to explain
things as simple as possible
before i go into what exact topic we're
talking about
um
you know let's um
let's try to figure out
how do you think black should play here
and um
this is actually a little bit of a
follow-up on
uh caleb um caleb's lecture
uh interestingly enough this was not
pre-planned it was just happens to be
like that which
kind of kind of fitting so um
what would you do for black here and why
what do you think
yeah i guess it's
i guess it's fine i i mean it's just i
think the it's just that the
for me it's different because i'm
impressed yeah we all gotta wear masks
now okay sure yeah pardon me
not my call
yeah lombardi fisher yes
and so what i want to look at i'm just
not sure if it's
i'm looking at rook takes bishop and
then
the neighborhood takes
d5
and then trading works and
yes
very good yes so
what we do here is we transition into
this king and pawn and game
and king g5
king c4
and then we play
b6 a5
and then we make up outside past pawn
and
and uh
we win the game
so yeah because of the outside past pawn
um
okay so
the topic today is going to be
uh transitioning into the king and pawn
end game and basically trying to
understand when it's good when it's not
good
um you know so let's look at uh the next
example
um
actually let's do
this one first
all right this is also i think a fairly
straightforward one
how should white play in this position
uh
all right bishop takes pawn takes
all right that's uh
it's a possibility
um see any any other ideas
um
yeah start with rook d1
to force the training ropes as well
um
okay we can also do that we'll go over
both of these options
but let's see if any other ideas for for
white
all right so
let's see we have
g5 suggestion
okay so so far everybody has kind of
suggested parts of the
right answer but nobody got the
the
the full thing so
let's continue analyzing
okay somebody just got it yes bishop
takes f6
g takes f6 rook d1 so
right because this way we
guarantee a transition into a
into a king and pawn end game
by taking and then playing
rogue d1
you did say that but you said follow up
with g5
oh
oh oh sorry i didn't yeah i didn't i
didn't realize that it was uh like him
following your ideas right
um
yeah um
but i think it's important to see this
rook d1 move as well because if you
don't play rook d1
then
it's not that clear but um yeah rook d1
takes takes and then what happens is
white has
a chance to make a a past pawn
black could stop it but then white makes
a past pawn on this side of the board as
well
b5 takes c5 and white is
white is winning
um
so um
yeah rook g1 yeah i mean you can take
take and go 98 for example or even
knight xg4 right so these are
some of the
small problems um
and if you take take
g5 which was mentioned um
then um
then you don't have to take hg which
would allow rook d1 you can play
something like rook d8 or rook d4 and
then
the rook is able to be
on on the board
um
and g5 was also suggested but then
we play knight takes
h5
okay so uh anyway let's um let's
let's look at the next one
all right now the next ones will be
significantly
more more difficult so
you know we'll try to
kind of
go through them step by step this one
does not seem to be supposed to be so
difficult because it's just queen and
porn against queen and porn but actually
it's uh
there are some
nuances so
so let's try this white to play what
should i do
all right queen g5 is a
very interesting try
um obviously this is a trickier one
right because there are many transitions
into king and pawn and games we can have
here right so we
we need to decide which one would be
the one that's that's favorable for us
so
so queen if we play queen g5
uh if he takes then that will be winning
for white
um because we have this
we have this pawn on the fifth ring
and here the only thing we have to know
is not to go king f6 because then
here we cannot play g6 because of
stalemate so whenever we have a g pawn
it's important to go king h6
king h8
g6 and then g7
um
yeah um but um
instead of going queen takes g5 black
could play something like
queen f3
and uh and then black will start giving
a lot of checks
and uh and then it's not entirely easy
for
for white to
to play here
it's gonna be a draw because it's gonna
be very hard to get out of all these
checks
um
all right so
what else could white consider so queen
g5 is good try but he does not have to
take and chess is
not checkers you're not forced to take
it's important
king of six
yeah and then i mean what can we play um
king of six
okay
uh very good you got it
king of six is the best move um
so
we will take a look at that in a second
but let's just quickly see
why the other moves
are not as good
a lot of students suggest the move
queen h5
and then f5 but then it's just a draw
you know we
queen at equal times
and
also people suggest king f8
with the idea that after this
takes
g5 here here here
here queen
white is winning
but after this black actually has queen
f5
and this is still a draw because after
takes takes here
black needs to play precisely go king h8
oh the only drawing move
that way after this
and this we're able to go king f7 and
get the opposition
going in front of the the pawn
um
and king f7 we can play g5
um
but king of sex is the absolutely best
move here
um and now if you go queen e5 fe5 king
g8
this is winning trivially because of
takes
here here here in king e6
we get the opposition
um
if queen h4 we go king of seven
queen h6 let's say queen f6 and black
isn't zugswank black is forced to either
lose a porn or
or get mated
and
and finally
black has one more
interesting try king h6
after which the win is still
a bit tricky
so let's see if anyone
could find this
i mean you're not really obligated to
see that ahead of time if you play king
of six but
i guess it's good to try to find now as
a as an exercise
believe it or not it's still the only
way to win here but it's kind of
not that not that obvious
it was not even mentioned in the book by
the way from where i got the problem
king h6 which is
kind of a
important omission by the book author
okay sure
um yeah the problem with queen g5 is
actually after takes takes king h5
um this is a mutual zugswank we're
actually the ones
we're actually the ones that that is
that is losing here
here
all right looks like fun smart content
got it
king of seven and now if queen of five
take take king f6
and after g5 we have
king f8
threatening queen g7
and uh after this we have queen h8
um
yeah and we're threatening queen g7
um
yeah so this is uh this is the winning
idea for white king of seven
but yes very nice king of six very
important move only winning move here
okay let's see some other examples
okay here's an interesting
rook and game
puzzle
so
it's a black to play
black could play
rook a1 immediately or he can give a
check first
and then play rook a1 next move
which one do you think is better and and
why
so why would you want to have the king
on e6 or e7 or somewhere else instead of
d6
for black because you're going to have
to play rook a1 next move anyway
so
oh i was tripping i'm looking at
something different i was thinking
white i don't know why i was looking at
white people
i was looking at the wrong way
it's okay
all right so we have not checking allows
the bridge with rook d8 rook d7
um
okay one rook d8 rook a6 right maybe
rookie okay
so so basically what we what we have to
realize is that if black plays let's say
in the media at rook a1 or whatever
white has only one winning idea here
um
because if he's gonna try to get close
to the pawn he's just gonna be forever
checked
right so that's not gonna
be able to win right so the only winning
possibility for white
is to somehow
move the rook away
and then try to exchange the rooks so
for example rook d8 rook c8 rook e8
somewhere and then after takes rook
check and then exchange the
the rooks try to get a winning
winning the
king and pawn end game
and now we just have to understand which
of the pawn end games will be winning
and which one will be
will be a draw
all right so the question is
what should white
uh
do in this position uh i mean sorry what
should black do should we go rook d1
first or should we play rook a1
um
i see some discussion going on on
youtube some relevant discussion
so i'll give you guys maybe a
a minute or two more
oh
all right rogue d1 prevent prevents uh
bridge building okay well
it doesn't technically but we'll
so
the first question is after rk1 what is
the
what is the move that white has to play
what is the move why it should play to
try to have any winning chances
there are three ways to try to exchange
rooks but only one way that actually
accomplishes it
so which which one white would need to
play
no the pawn is going like this
pawn's going like this so this is the
next square like we're trying to queen
yes
right right
yes
uh yeah if you go king e6 i'll i'll give
a check and then i'll go back right
that's
that's not really
gonna
give you anything
even if you play e5
you know even if somehow
you take play this position you're not
going to be able to get the g5 pawn but
even if somehow you do this is still a
draw
this is still a draw because
with the pawn array all the way on a7
and with the g pawn you can never make
progress g or an h pawn because the king
just stays there
and you don't have progress to be made
so
the only idea is moving the rook but
where
rook d8
actually would be a mistake because
after rook a6 chap
we're not able to
make progress we're just going to lose
the pawn and we're not going to be able
to exchange
same thing after rook e8 after rookie 8
there's rook a6 check
very strong check
again disturbs our harmony and then
we're going to take on a7 and there's no
no way to make progress unfortunately so
the only way to guarantee a rook trade
is rook c8
because then after check we have rook c6
i mean we don't have to trade rooks but
then of course we will
now we'll lose this rook end game
because now the king will get to
b8 and white will be able to promote the
pawn
fairly easily
so black
will play rook takes a7
at some point or
and then
we give this check and now the question
is is this a winning position for white
or not and the answer is yes it's
winning because we have a distant
opposition here three squares apart and
black has to
you know
play like this and then eventually we
will
go here
and do this out flanking strategy
we win the pawn and then the rest is
is very simple so we need to play rook
c8 but if we start with rook d1 check
white plays king e6 and then we go here
now rook c8 does not work anymore
so and rookie a does not work because of
the check
so the only option then is to play rook
d8
if rook takes a7
rook d7
but the difference now is this position
is a draw because it's it's black to
play
and black has a way to get the
opposition but it's still not over we
need to know exactly how we get that
position
because there's only one move that still
draws here and we have to be very very
careful so what is the drawing move for
black here
all right
very good king h7 because if we go king
f7
we will not be able to maintain the
opposition because of this pawn so
after this for example here here here we
will lose right but after the very
important of king h7 now it's black who
gets that position
and no matter what y does
black is able to
make the
the draw
so if we go all the way back here
you see how first you have to identify
why it's only winning idea here why it's
only winning plan and once we've
established white's winning plan then we
need to understand
where would we need their king to be for
their plan not to work as well and you
have to be able to understand king and
poland games in order to do that right
so you see how in all of these examples
so far in order to be able to play
properly these queen and rook end games
you have to understand the basic
concepts of the opponent games that's
where to all of you who are learning end
games make sure you start with opponent
games because if you don't know your
opponent games you know like it's two
plus two
then um the other end games will be even
just how much that much harder it's the
same thing as trying to learn algebra
without understanding arithmetic right
so that's why pawn end games
are the most important the basic pawn
end games
all right so let's
continue
okay so here's an another interesting
question
so white has an opportunity of course to
play knight d6
and exchange everything on e8
um
should white do it or not
should white go into the pawn and game
here or not
important question why why not try to
give as detailed of our answer as
possible if you think they should not
explain what would be the drawing line
for black or waiting line if yes explain
the winning line till then so
so in other words should white play
knight d6 follow barrow k8 or why should
white not
by the way to those of you who are very
interested in this topic
uh liquidation and support and games
there is a book out there joel benjamin
grandma's legendary grandmaster joel
benjamin wrote this book
um
won multiple u.s championships
he wrote a book whole book just on the
topic of liquidating into pawning games
so if you guys
like this topic
make sure you
you get this book
um okay anyway so white to play
do we go knight d6 or not i wouldn't be
even surprised if some of these end
games are in his book maybe not i'm not
sure
i'm guessing we should so we can
use that
outside
on the queen
okay but yeah we have an outside
basketball and true but black also has
his own stuff going on on the king side
too so we have
to okay so let's um
let's go over this so
chess king says after knight d6 here
takes takes takes takes king g3
f5
then he goes kingdom seven kings of six
stops the pawn okay that's
this in that sense black he's right that
this is already
good for black because even if white
plays e4 here black plays f4 and gets a
protected passport
and now
this will only be a draw this will be a
this will be a draw
after a5 b5
um
so king lear says we should swap
a file by king g3 i think in that case i
can go f5 and then e4
and or something like that and then i
think also this is a this is a draw
because i have a protected passport and
you cannot
win here but um
a few people
said that e4
we can play here and that is the key
point of this
position because the point of e4
is that
when he goes g6 we go here
f5 takes takes and now we have past
pawns on both sides of the board right
and now we're able to win the game he
cannot possibly stop both passports and
these pawns could be located at least
for now okay maybe in the in like 10
moves black can win but white is
way way faster here
and uh i mean he can try not to play a
five but then white also wins
with h5 and then the
he will come around and win the
the f6 pawn um so pretty much no matter
what black does the key move to be able
to find is this movie 4
which kind of stops these pawns on the
tracks
knowing that you can't cannot play g6 f5
giving the white def
given giving white to h5 pawn
and now you just prepare king g3 king g4
h5 king of five before a4 and white is
kind of um
kind of better
um
okay so white instead played king g3
and uh
king g3 first but the problem is now
black was able to play rook h7
and uh knight d6 king e7 and uh
black does not a white is not able to
get into the
king and king and ponan game anymore and
this becomes uh
later on the game ended up being a draw
so if you see a transition you know it
might be winning you have to really try
to calculate it explore all your options
okay
this was also from a famous game i think
it was
smith's love
all right so
here
black to play
what should black black what should
black do
all right uh
so
rookie seven is uh
is the the correct move
um
because after rookie seven you take take
well actually i don't think we're
playing king d7 here i think because
then king e5
we still have this past pawn we can try
to make here and i think
white's king is pretty active i think in
fact we want to play king f6 trying to
go king g5
and try to make a
pass pawn here i think that's the
that's the idea in the game there was
this this
and then came g6 and h5
all right
so rookie 7 was the correct idea
um
all right for this one
i'll give you guys a tactical puzzle
first and then we'll
look at an end game as well so this is a
game
smirnoff and against abdul satorov both
very talented young players
abdul satoru is very young he became a
gm and when he was 12 or maybe 13 at
most
okay
so here's a
exercise for you so
um what should white
do in this position make sure you don't
just give one move but give a
give the follow-up
sorry renee what was that supposed to
mean i'm a little bit confused
yeah rook d a does not work because of f
takes g5 right
if we go queen g7 queen g7 rook d8 that
does not work
um
yeah here we lose a piece
um
so
queen g4 is the correct move
but the question is what happens in case
of rook f4
what's the what's the idea here
yes exactly
rook d8
that's the key move i think that's what
white missed right he just maybe stopped
after four but rook d8
is completely winning it's gonna be
takes takes and he's gonna be up two
exchanges
uh if rook d8 queen takes on queen g7
and rook g3 you know you take take queen
a4
so the real point why we go queen g4
is because of in the game white played
queen g6 it also looks very promising
we're threatening rook g8 but
the problem is black is able to play
rook t3
and uh limit the damage
yeah and then the game proceeded for
like many moves
and you know white should still probably
be winning but you know white was having
a hard time converting it and then after
a bunch of moves were made
i wanna
get to
an important uh
moment here yeah so white kind of messed
it up and now we got this position
um what should black
do this what should blood do here
oh why bishop a force but yeah i guess
he
black also made a blunder yes
probably um
so
all right looks like me and meg got it
uh yes pmd got it too yes so if we play
a normal move like queen c5 we're
probably not gonna win right
and after queen g3 queen g3 if we just
take back this is also not winning
because king e4 but the key idea to find
is this very nice king e6
waiting move because the thing is he's
not actually threatening to
he cannot save his queen anyway and that
gives us a very important tempo
to
you know
to activate our king and now black is
winning here by one temple of course
here we play king b3
and we don't allow the king to get to c3
and black will promote the pawn let's
say here
and then import move king b2 of course
a4 would still allow the draw but king
b2 of course
all right
next one
okay this is uh looks like a study but
this is actually from a real game this
was asean asthma perishable against
jean-chan two very strong grandmasters
how should white
convert it
well white is clearly better he can win
a pawn if he wants he can do several
things
he has a very active king black's king
is in a dangerous spot
but how should white try to
to win this position
all right
um
so
i'm thinking
we should check the king until we can
kind of
fork the king and queen to force the
trade and then
okay i mean if you can do that that
would be nice but how can we do that
can we actually do that
all right queen b6 king
c8 um
g8
sorry now
so quintex a5 is a very tempting so the
checks don't really lead to anything so
we have to look for captures and maybe
checkmate threats the other forcing
moves
um quintex a5 looks like it should win
um
but black has a fascinating way to make
a draw here
um
let's see if anyone can actually find
the draw for black after queen a5
because queen of five looks like it wins
too
because like a lot of these pawn end
games look like they're winning but
black has a
really nice way to
make the draw
which white i'm sure missed during the
game
queen d6 queen b6
well it's a check queen b6 is a check
it doesn't look like it works it looks
like we've forced the trade queens but
until we realize that we don't have to
take
king c8 or king a8 and if we take it
it's a stalemate
so white cannot take but then if he does
not take then we start checking right we
get counter play and this becomes
a draw
so queen a5 does not win because of this
fascinating reason that we don't have to
go into the king and bonang game but
queen c6 does win
so
if queen here
we win the following way we go queen b5
check
take stakes
let's say four a try but then of course
we take with the king not the pawn we
don't want the a pawn
and after this we get the opposition
uh are you calling it the eric rosen
idea yeah i guess it's
yeah and if here
this is also win because we have we have
a spare temple to gain
um
but black does not give up yet so easily
he plays queen before
trying to stop the mate and you know now
you have to decide how you proceed here
white needs to find one more strong move
so if he wants to win the game
uh if you go queen f4 then i'll
happily exchange queens with you and
then you're gonna be stuck with the ape
one with which you cannot
ever win
when the king stops it
so the ap1 is notoriously known for
being droish
um
if we play queen b5 check
it looks like it wins because after this
it's the same thing but he doesn't have
to take he can play king c8
and then it's not
easy to win because after this for
example
the king is able to
get the opposition now you we could
probably still go back and go and maybe
maybe we can still win sorry with some
move like queen of five
but uh we would still have to find the
correct idea
after king b8 anyway right so
so
yeah we might as well find it
right away and queen b6 is also a
mistake because then takes takes a4 it's
an immediate draw
and if we go check and queen
e7 we're gonna lose the queen so we
don't want to do that
move earlier
um
queen d7 queen
queen where did you say d5 or b4
yeah b5 we already looked at king c
yeah it's okay yeah queen queen d7 is
very powerful because the threatening
queen d8 mate
yeah their black has no checks and um
you cannot stop either queen d8 or queen
b7 and you cannot stop
all the mates at once so
yeah this is very nice
28 checkmate
yeah that's what that's the threat yeah
black
is lost
um let's just see
what we have
okay this is a game i played against the
your future gmail residents
brian smith
you guys will see him in a week
um
in fact i think he's coming even a
little bit earlier but
his his residence officially starts on
november 10th i think
um yeah so this is a game i played
against him and
at some point we had this end game
and the question is
should black play queen f7 or not
why or why not
no
why not
on f7
the kings
well technically no i mean white could
white has other moves too
but
but i feel like if white does not take
queen f7 looks like kind of a favorable
move for black
but um
yeah i mean queen f7 is uh
of course the committal move so
so what do you guys think should is
queen f7 good for black and why why not
so the real question is what happens
after queen takes off seven does
does white win is it a draw or does
white lose
that's uh
that's the real question
all right so how so queen takes king
takes
how does white win
all right so i'll play five
yes i want to go king e6 king d6 and
claim that i have a past porn and
and you don't so
all right so let's try to look at it a
little bit deeply yeah so this is a
a little bit of a of a trick question
um
i'll give you maybe
one or two more minutes
so the real question after queen of
seven would you
would you exchange or would you not
like it's um
queen of three okay queen f3 is a
different story i mean queen of three at
least we don't have to take then
intuitively
the king yeah also we don't don't forget
h5 in some lines is hanging maybe but
then
i mean
yeah i mean
but okay if if queen takes f7 wins then
you know you really want to play queen
of seven don't you
so
but if it loses
then
probably you play another move whatever
it is
so
so the real question is not what the
best move is just evaluate queen of
seven like what happens after queen of
seven
is white winning is white losing or is
that a draw
well if we go queen f7 and g6 i don't
think that's good because takes takes
takes and then we
we're gonna now
lose here yeah
um okay so someone says king g3 yes so
the correct idea is actually
queen f7 is the best move and white
actually wins those of you who told
white wins
congratulations but the question is how
because this one it looks like
black is winning but the key thing that
i missed when i played queen f7 was
i missed
the smooth king f3
which is uh which is extremely annoying
and he gains a very important tempo and
now it turns out that when i play here
king e4
king is seven
king takes e5
and king d7
black white has a very annoying move
here which
which wins him the game
which what is the move
well actually i'm thinking now maybe
it's more than one move but i was
thinking just c4
c4
takes king c4 and then
the thing is this is winning for white
because white has an outside past pawn
so for example
here we go king c4
a4 b5 and
for example here let's say here
and 6
here
um
yeah white will be winning because of
the outside past pawn so it's kind of
neat we started with the outside
passport example
and we kind of finished with an outside
passport example
um
instead i played d5 and i thought that
okay maybe it's at least a draw but the
problem is i lose because after this
he played this move h6
kings come in but the problem is he has
this
very important
spare tempo
and we can play a3
and now this is
winning for white because black is in
zuk's wank
king b7 is met by king d6
and king d7 is met by king b6
um okay um
there is um
just to kind of recap
you know we talked a lot about
um you know transitions in the port end
games but since some of you guys
mentioned to me the
game against 7 that i had in the u.s
championship i figured i'll throw it in
today and i'll just cover one important
critical moment from that game
from the end game
of course i will not cover
all of the
140 moves that were in the game
but i'll just cover the
the starting position here of this end
game so here we have an end game which
two bishops against bishop and knight
and i have an extra pawn it should be
winning but as you guys
many of you saw i was having a very hard
time converting it and eventually i did
win after 140 moves but i did allow him
to draw a couple of times which he
missed
and so my technique was far from ideal
um
so the question is um
what should the white plate and then the
last question was taken on e5
immediately necessary no it was not but
i was it was still losing no matter what
i mean i checked it with the computer um
anyway let's let's look at this one so
i'll just ask you for one
moment right here what do you guys think
would be the best plan for white here
the reason i'm throwing it in today is
because it's a little bit of a review
from the from the topic that i talked
about
in the last lesson which was about
principle of two weaknesses
um
and
this one applies here as well
i feel
and uh during the game i didn't find the
right plan and as a result i have a
very
difficult task of of winning so
the question is how do we try to
create a second weakness here and what
could be the
the best uh plan
bishop b5 is actually what i played um
but then
let's say he goes knight f8
yeah i mean we can do that but then i
can play knight e6 let's say bishop b6
f i don't know king f8 and then the
thing is once i play c5 he goes knight
d4 and he locates the pawn
to eventually get the
uh pawn on e7 to move well he can't move
because it'll be in shape yeah
yeah
yeah i mean then i'll probably go king
of eight then i'll play f6 king seven
i'll still be able to activate the king
um h4h5 like a super gm well then i
think black can play g5 maybe i'm not
sure yeah i think jfix is correct we
want to play a four here
and the idea actually over four is
what we really want to accomplish here
is we want to gain more space play a
five g4
and then the idea is bringing the king
up
and maybe even exchange the bishops
and what f4 five does is that
like let's say he plays knight of eight
like in the game
um
we could try a five and uh the thing is
it fixes that pawn on
angie's on g7 which could be
rather weak right so it's going to be
very difficult for him to activate the
king
as a result
um and
if he plays f5 he cannot really do that
because bishop c4 bishop e6 right so
that's kind of important
so the real idea is i want to play g4 f5
king of two king e3
and he's going to be tied down to his
to his king side right i'm gonna at some
point
create either a weak g pawn or
something along those lines right and
he cannot he does not really have a
a great way to play here
um
like that of fate we can probably play
f5
um or although you can also go king f2
here bishop e5
f6 this and then
play maybe
activate the king a little bit later as
well but
i i personally think that
f5 is is probably even easier
um
yeah i mean it's still a difficult end
game to convert but i think if i would
have caught the right plan earlier i
probably could have had a chance to win
easier but
instead i played at some point the move
f3 which was
uh not that great
it kind of um
it does block the
bishop but the thing is the [ __ ] i
don't really need to restrict the bishop
here the bishop still has
room to go
and then later on he kind of got a
little bit of a fortress type position
and
yeah i was having a hard time trying to
trying to convert that and
yeah like i said um later on it was
could have been a draw but
i was able to win the game so just a
little bit of a review of of that
previous topic i thought
um all right so
hope you guys enjoyed it did you guys
have any preference for next
because my next tuesday will be my last
end game course so does anyone have a
specific preference on which
exact endgame topic you guys
would want to see for next or next week
uh please type it in your chat if you
want to
see something in in particular and i'll
do my best to accommodate that
so
all right queen endgames please okay
i'll try to i'll try to definitely
include some queen end games
all right love the pawn end game okay so
porn and games
um
all right so the thing about queen end
games and porn and games they both all
right somebody's saying minor peace and
game okay so that's
a little bit
um
all the options yeah uh
what about you guys what do you think
and somebody said rook end games which
uh
of course are also very instructive and
okay we got another vote for rokan games
so
um
okay well we'll uh we'll do our best
i'll try to
yeah most practical are rooken games yes
um
i actually have some very instructive
rook end games
um
but they're probably but that's that's
probably material for like
masters and above so i i also want to
make sure i you know i don't
kill you guys
uh
ah you mean uh bridge from middle game
to end game yeah something like that
like i think
middle game to end game transition okay
um yeah i mean that that could be uh
could be an option yeah
imbalance situations like knife versus
bishop
yeah minor piece and game
potentially yeah
knight against bishop to bishop against
bishop or or knight against knight right
clump complex okay so it seems like
everybody wants something a little bit
different so i'll
i'll have to be creative and think about
the best content there
yeah we'll see uh i'll have to
ponder on that a little bit and um
you know we'll uh
so i'll see you guys uh
next week then for my
last end game course i hope you guys
enjoyed it and i'll see you next week
thank you
[Music]
you